their deals that have long been in the
spotlight two for one on junk food
saving cash from the supermarket to the
Shelf we know that low-income families
are looking for essentially getting more
calories into a into a more uh cost
effective basket not because they're
particularly greedy not because they're
obese because they're you know they have
very little to play with when it comes
to funds available for feeding their
kids basically but there's politics here
too debate over in Nanny State and now a
policy already pushed back delayed
another two years
the row back on two for one deals is
about the government's broader obesity
strategy about helping services like the
NHS it spends billions of pounds a year
on Obesity that was a longer term
strategy but in the short term this is a
government looking at a general election
sometime soon that we fought on the cost
of living
with the new prime minister has come new
priorities Boris Johnson was a PM behind
the Obesity push today raising the
subject again in his much-anticipated
mail column an MP is still in Parliament
have a view too buy one get one freeze
tend to be impulse buys and uh
statistics have shown that on average
people spend 22 percent more than they
were planning to do so um so it's not
saving the money it's actually costing
money
with more Bleak warnings today about
Rising mortgages the Prime Minister
knows there's one thing on people's
minds when I do go shopping my big
shopping weekly shopping
um now it's always over 100 pounds and
there's just two of us I think it
changes every week you go it's
definitely like the basics are more
expensive is that something you'd think
about when you're voting at the next
section definitely yeah and with an
election not far off the balance between
health and Rising bills has been decided
Ali full Sky News Westminster